furry friends have been a welcome
diversion for many from the often
miserable monotony of life in lockdown
there's no evidence that household pets
contract or carry Co vid 19 like they're
human owners but they're in isolation to
these cocker spaniels are being cared
for by the RSPCA York but Britain's
biggest animal charity predicts this and
other centers may be forced to close
there's there's gonna be nothing any of
those centers can do really to bring in
the level of income they need to run the
center like ours cost about sixty
thousand pounds a month to run and we
seen 80 to 90% of our income just gone
in a week it's an impossible situation
to be in our animals in in danger you
said you know you can't rehome animals
at the moment does that put them at risk
longer term I think there could be
problems you know we see in other
countries where abandonments have spiked
as a result of the corona virus and
people being in lockdown so there is a
good chance that people are just going
to decide the colic after their pets
anymore and you know either
turn them over to centers or abandon
them on the streets down the road at
this Food Bank demand has doubled in
just the last week so at the moment
we're really getting low on tin tomatoes
and fruit this is an unremitting an
indiscriminate crisis for the entire
sector it's estimated charities will
lose around 3.7 billion pounds in income
over the next 12 weeks many businesses
can rely on government relief packages
to pay they're laid off employees but
for charities that's simply not possible
organizations like food banks like
homeless shelters and hospices and more
desperately needed than ever before but
they're also battling a funding
apocalypse like never before
if this lockdown continues much longer
smaller charities that will struggle to
survive and the bigger ones won't be far
behind them either but with many of the
most vulnerable in isolation bags of
essential items like tinned fruit tinned
meat and toilet rolls have been packed
for delivery
waiting at the other end is jane who's
in the high-risk category and his self
isolating a run short of food yesterday
and she said don't worry ground i'll
ring this lady the lady rang me back
this morning and i had a delivery I
can't believe what a nice thing people
do for other people the gentleman next
door that wants me he can't go out the
lady there can't go out there's none of
us in this block can go out as the new
normal takes hold charities like the
rest of society are being forced to find
new solutions to deal with new problems
Martha Kellner Sky News York